Hello, Dr. Kevin Connors here and a little discussion today on low testosterone and different natural ways
That you can address this with you or a loved one. What is low T?
Well, there's a lot of information out there right now because there is an FDA approved
synthetic testosterone
And they are pushing it big time
Television could you problem be low T all of a sudden they have a drug for something
And everybody's got a new disease, right?
Well, it is true that you could have low testosterone level
So we don't want to just ignore this as another drug fan try to get you to another medication
Symptoms of fatigue for bed as they get older
erectile dysfunction reduce sex from drive reduced
general vitality in life
increased weight gain
Could all be symptoms of low T so we don't want to just ignore it
And we want to look at it from a more natural perspective
Testosterone influence is a lot of parts of our body. So it's something we want to look at
So there's different tests that we could do in our office. I like to run labs on hormones. So
This test right here from ZRT lab is actually available in our store that you could
purchase and run. It's very easy. It's called a blood spot test
So it actually comes with little finger prickers that you put it on those little road circles your drops of blood
Send it back in and we get a really nice reading of testosterone levels. It's relatively inexpensive
And it's a good way to check if low T is an issue if it is an issue
Then we need to look at things on this presentation. So if my issue is a low testosterone level
There's some possible solutions. What is to go to your medical doctor and get the synthetic
Testosterone
So edre gel is one of those synthetic testosterones that they're pushing very heavily on television right now
It's something I would not ever suggest
So just so you know using synthetic core modes
can be
Huge problems. So there's just a lot of possible side effects with synthetic testosterone
That it's just not worth going down that road especially when there's so many natural alternatives
Number one we could use bio identical testosterone
So that's a great possible substitute. No, that's the second choice that I would choose
I'll tell you the first choice and just a second but bioaddedical hormones is fantastic
So using bio identical hormones for the right reason could be a life saver for so many people when and women
So bio identical testosterone is available. So we
Use that in our office, but I always start with this natural stimulants
So on the list here I'm not going to read all these but there's a lot of natural stimulants out there that are just so good
It just help balance it your hormones because many times
low testosterone is a function of
Of a brain issue. So by hypothalmus
Gladiate in my brain part of my brain
stimulates my pituitary which then stimulates so many other hormone functions and what is the release of testosterone?
So I could have because of increased stress because of you know just so many
Frontal lobe issues, anxiety, ADD issues could affect my testosterone output because that affects my hypothalmus, my hippocampus, and my pituitary that output
That's why on this list, if you look now, this lip cordisps and ashwagandha are so good at
Balanced testosterone levels because they basically help balance that pituitary link
so
That's where I like to start with whatever we're dealing with any hormone imbalances is to look at the braid, calm the braid,
Decrease that
Support the hypothalmus pituitary link and that's a great place to start some of the products that I like
Are this designs for health libido stem and this libido stem
M and F, it's for male and female. However, I use the libido stem F in a lot of men
Tests out really well for them. It has deer antler in it as well, which could be really help with stamina in issues too
so but the libido stem M has just a
multitude of different herbal and nutrients that just help bring up testosterone levels and not just testosterone
Just help balance hormone levels in men and women just great good natural stimulants
Also, you got to look at natural lifestyle changes. I mean dietary components even even something like a gluten sensitivity could decrease the person's testosterone level because it fires to the frontal lobe
So a gluten sensitivity could have a gluteal morphine effect on the braid to those receptor sites and could decrease frontal lobe communication
To the hypothalmus
So
Diet is a huge important not just weight loss, but looking at leaky gut issues, etc
Exercise is really important for testosterone levels. So many times as people get elderly
like me, we fail to exercise the way we should and
also not getting enough sleep. So
Listen to my braid drain series about sleep and how important it is to help clear inflammation out of your braid
But sleep weight loss exercise level different dietary changes are really important
There's just some different foods that you could add to your diet too
pumpkin seeds are really good eggs
Walnuts chia seeds garlic and different beans can help increase testosterone levels
They all have good nutrients in it that are precursors for testosterone
So by suggestion with somebody with low T is number one if that's if you're watching the television commercials
And that's something that you that you think that you might have I know especially with ED it can be
The huge issue should I just go on some ED medication or do I have
You want to always dig to why do you have that? So get your testosterone levels checked
That's a great place to start if that's not the issue at all
Then you want to keep digging to ask the question why?
So those
Stimulators that libido stib
Amin F are good even if a person doesn't have less low testosterone levels
So there's other good nutrients in there and having a good diet is super important
But this gives you just a brief idea always start with the
The natural stimulants next step would be the bioidenticals
I would never go to the synthetic hormones. So just your information. All right Dr. Cutters hope this was helpful